you think hey I'm going to leave this to
go do this I'm going to go give this a
try I'm going to open this coffee shop
you think you can never go back yeah and
of course you can go back if you were in
the hospital for a year would you be
sitting there going I can never go back
to my job no you would
know there's going to it's going to be
an adjustment period I might have some
catchup I have to you know there's but
you you just go get another job like
that's how life works right and but
especially when you're younger and you
don't have the experience it feels like
the shift or the transition or the the
quitting can never be
undone and only with time you realize
that the stakes were so much lower than
you thought they
were